one of the teams looking for both a new
gm and a new head coach the houston
texans they've announced that they have
met with jim caldwell former cults and
lions head coach to be the texans head
coach now it's a little bit
backwards
to hire or to at least consider coaches
before you have a gm and it makes me
wonder who's going to have the juice in
houston and they said met i thought
there was a memo that said they can only
do virtual meetings through the end of
the season maybe they maybe they're just
taking the liberty with the term and
nowadays that's how 98 of all meetings
happen anyway but caldwell as a
potential candidate to coach the texans
that's fine as long as the next gm is on
board with caldwell being the coach to
the texans and i'd hate to think that
the texans are thinking seriously about
coaching candidates until they know who
the gm is going to be sharing
yeah it seems weird mike that they would
meet with him now but it does fulfill
obviously the rooney rule but i hope
they're giving him serious consideration
and this isn't just to comply with the
rooney rule which is what it seems
frankly right now but i do hope if
they're interviewing they give them
serious consideration and this isn't
just to check off that box that hey we
we've done our minority interview and
now we can move on with who we really
want let's take this seriously and
interview some candidates who you really
want to hire and jim caldwell certainly
deserves to be in that category of
coaches you would serious seriously
consider with what he did in
indianapolis and then frankly what he
did in detroit and what detroit's done
after he left there but let's hope it's
just not checking that box mike
62 and 50 as a head coach and if i
recall correctly when we were critiquing
john gruden last week 63 and 79 is his
record since winning a super bowl so 62
and 50 i'm no math wiz i think 62 and 50
is better than 63 and 79 also won the
2009 afc championship with the colts and
that banner is better than 2014 afc
finalists so he's got that going for him
as well his banner is better than chuck
pagano's banner in indianapolis
caldwell was fired by the lions in 2017
after a pair of nine and seven seasons
the lions stunk ever since then and look
this this this was a product of bob
quinn going in there knowing you wanted
matt patricia this is the dynamic that
we're talking about as it relates to the
panthers bob quinn was hired by the
lions with caldwell as the coach and
quinn knew he was going to hire matt
patricia the question is when was he
going to do it some general managers
will wash out the coach and not give the
coach a chance and rip the band-aid off
in one motion others will give the coach
a chance to show that the coach needs to
go the problem is caldwell had a pair of
nine and seven seasons and it made it
awkward when they finally did move on
from jim caldwell so i think caldwell
will be
inherently sensitive to the idea shireen
that
i'd like to at least have a clue as to
who the gm is going to be before you
would hire me i don't want to be in a
situation where the gm that wants to get
rid of me and and also as it relates to
the rooney rule
my sense this year i haven't heard this
but this is just the broader
circumstance and context given so much
of the emphasis that is flowing from the
league office on increasing the number
of minority coaches and general managers
i think teams are going to grossly over
comply with the rooney rule requirement
which is good
i still think at the end of the day the
owners are going to hire who they want
to hire but the more and this is one of
the reasons they came up with the rooney
rule the more that minority candidates
are talked about and interviewed and
discussed and considered the thinking is
that it will become a self-fulfilling
prophecy that those individuals get
opportunities at some point but i think
we're going to see
significant over compliance none of this
check the box do the bare minimum the
crap that the texans pulled a couple of
years ago and i'm i can't say all due
respect because it was crap they fire
brian gaine they want nick casario they
pre-interviewed two minority candidates
i think it was ray farmer and another
one if you know it let's shout it out
and then they decided they couldn't get
casario so we're not going to have a gm
never mind the fact that we interviewed
two minority candidates um we're just go
we're good we're fine with what we have
er
i think rod graves was at the
uh fritz paul alliance at the time
whoever was running the time was not
happy with the way that was handled and
i i don't think we're going to have that
this year we're going to have over
compliance and that's a good thing and
we'll see ultimately
whether the texans or anyone else will
hire a minority gm or a minority head
coach but where we are right now
five
three coaches two weeks to go in the
regular season
and we'll see how many more shireen
openings come i think we've seen the
bulk of them already i think teams want
to get a head start i don't think we're
gonna have a big a big avalanche
of firings after the regular season ends
jacksonville jets who else mike that may
be it that may be all we're looking at
uh
as far as head coaches go the rest of
the way that we
probably have seen the bulk of those
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports